FRIENDS. SCOTT WIENER AND ANNA
CAVIAR TO COME DOWN AND PRESENT
THEIR BILLS AND SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HERE.
ALAN HERE. ALAN HERE, DOLLY
DOLLY! HERE GONZALES IS HERE.
BROUGH. MENJIVAR. MANAGEMENT
RIGHT HERE WHEN ONE HERE.
SKINNER. OKAY SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM. I AM CALLING CENTER
WINNER RIGHT NOW. HE APPARENTLY
WAS WONDERING HALLS. YEAH.
DO YOU WANNA WILL? THANK YOU FOR
REQUESTING UP HERE. APPRECIATE
IT. ALL RIGHT. SO WE'VE GOT CENA
CABALLERO, WHO'S HERE? UM
PRESENTING SB 768. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR FLEXIBILITY THIS
MORNING. ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SP 768 TODAY FIRST, LET
ME SAY THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE WILLINGNESS TO
ACCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS AS
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS DUE TO THE
TIMING ISSUES AND ALSO FOR WHAT
I THINK IS A REAL ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON SOMETHING THAT, UM
SOMETHING. THAT SETS UP. Tð
IMPOSSIBILITIES AT THE SAME TIME
. I KNOW THAT INCONSISTENCIES
AND IN STATE LAW ARE RARE,
RIGHT, BUT, UM, BUT IN MY
COMMUNITY, WHICH IS A RURAL
AGRICULTURAL REGION. UM THIS
PARTICULAR THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED HAS A
DELETERIOUS IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY TO CREATE THE HOUSING
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED AND
PART OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
BEGGING FOR HOUSING, BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW THEY GET THE STORES.
YEAH AND THE PHARMACIES THAT THE
SERVICES THAT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE RESIDENTS. SO,
UM SO A LITTLE HISTORY LESSON IS
IN 2013. THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A BILL BY
SENATOR STEINBERG, WHICH
ESTABLISHED A SPECIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE AND JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS UNDER SEQUA FOR
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO TO
STREAMLINE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE GOLDEN ONE
CENTER. THE PROBLEM WITH DOING
INFILL DEVELOPMENT IS THAT IF
YOU HAVE URBAN STREETS THAT ARE
IMPACTED, UM, AND ARE ALREADY
SERVING AT A LEVEL D OR F THEN
YOU CAN'T BUILD SEQUA. IT
PROVIDES A OBSTRUCTION TO
BUILDING IN PHIL'S INFILL
PROJECTS, AND SO AS A WAY TO
ADDRESS THIS, UM THE BILL TASKED
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH OPR WITH
THE TEST TO DEVELOP NEW SEQUEL
GUIDELINES. IT'S COME UP WITH
SOMETHING NEW SO WE CAN GET
THESE KINDS OF INFILL PROJECTS
DONE WHICH ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU MEET THE
WALKABLE COMMUNITY STANDARDS.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET TO A
URBANIZED CENTER AND UTILIZE
THAT THE PROPERTY BETTER SO THE
GUIDELINES WERE TO REPLACE THE
CURRENT CRITERIA TO MEASURE
TRANSPORTATION IMPACTS
PREVIOUSLY THAT WAS CALLED THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE OR CLOSE. AND
THE LEVEL OF SERVICE BECAUSE YOU
COULDN'T IMPROVE THEM WITH
INFILL PROJECTS. UM STYMIED THE
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE TO MITIGATE UNDER
SEQUA. AH SO IN 2020 OPR DEVISED
ANOTHER METHODOLOGY TO SATISFY
SEQUA FOR INFILL PROJECTS, UM IN
TRANSIT PRIORITY AREAS. I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT TRANSIT
PRIORITY AREAS. AH, AND THEY AND
THAT WAS THE VEHICLE. MILES
TRAVELED. THAT'S THAT'S A
GENESIS OF VEHICLE. MILES
TRAVELED FOR INFILL PROJECTS
THAT HAVE TRANSIT. UH PRIORITY.
UM VM T IS A MEASUREMENT OF HOW
MANY VEHICLE TRIPS ARE GENERATED
BY A PROJECT AND FOR INFILL LIKE
I SAID, UM, TO MITIGATE IT, UM,
IT ALLOWS THE INCREASED DENSITY
IT ALLOWS URBAN DEVELOPMENT. UM
AND IT WAS A WAY TO PRETTY MUCH
GET AROUND LEVEL OF SERVICE, BUT
THE TOOL WAS EXTENDED. THE TOOL
WAS EXTENDED WAY BEYOND WHAT IT
WAS INITIALLY INTENDED TO IN A
BUDGET BILL. WHAT DO WE KNOW
ABOUT BUDGET BILLS? WERE
EXPECTED TO GO UP ON BUDGET
BILLS, AND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT POLICY AND
WHETHER IT WORKS IN THE BUDGET
BILLS. AND SO VM T WAS EXTENDED
TO THE WHOLE WORLD. AND LEVEL OF
SERVICE NO LONGER BECAME THE
MEASURE THAT YOU WOULD LOOK AT
TO MITIGATE DEVELOPMENT AND THIS
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT NUMBER
ONE IS THE LEGISLATURE VOTED FOR
IT THROUGH A BUDGET PROCESS AND
NUMBER TWO. THE ANALYSIS AT THE
BEGINNING NEVER INCLUDED RURAL
AREAS. IT NEVER INCLUDED SMALL
LITTLE COMMUNITIES, AND IT NEVER
INCLUDED. THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE SOME COMMUNITIES THAT AREN'T
BUILDING THE HOUSING THAT THEY
NEED. AND SO PEOPLE HAVE TO MOVE
FURTHER AND FURTHER OUT, WHICH
IS WHAT IMPACTS DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE, WHICH IS LOS BANOS HAS
BECOME A BEDROOM COMMUNITY OF
SILICON VALLEY. IT'S A GOOD HOUR
AND A HALF TWO HOUR DRIVE, BUT
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO BUY A HOUSE
IN IN LOS BANOS, AND THEY CAN
AFFORD TO HAVE A YARD FOR THEIR
KIDS. THEY DON'T SPEND ANY TIME
WITH THEIR KIDS, BUT THEY CAN
HAVE THAT. AND SO FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE LOS LLANOS, UM
TO ADD THE VM T REQUIREMENT NOW
KNOWS, UM AND DAUGHTER FIREBALL.
HURON DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT
ALL, BECAUSE, UM, THEY ARE
DESPERATELY LOOKING FOR HOUSING.
AND YET, UM WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
V M T MITIGATIONS THERE IT IS.
TRANSPORTATION PASSES RIGHT.
IT'S PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
PASSES ITS BICYCLE LANES. IT'S
UM IT'S WALKING PATHS. IT'S THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT YOU HAVE IN
URBAN CENTERS THAT JUST DON'T
MAKE ANY SENSE. IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. UM AND THEY ACTUALLY
DON'T MITIGATE BMT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE MOVING OUT THERE
BECAUSE IT'S THERE. THEY CAN
AFFORD SO THAT THE CHALLENGES IS
THE VM T OVERLAY HAS HAS HAS
REALLY PUT A STRAIN ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHO ARE TRYING TO
MEET THEIR HOUSING NEEDS AND THE
STRAIN IS THAT IT IT THE FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH REDUCING THE
VEHICLE. MILES TRAVELED. WHICH
AGAIN THESE COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO, UM, TO DO
ALL BY THEMSELVES. UM INCREASES
THE COST OF HOUSING BECAUSE IT'S
PASSED ON TO THE CONSUMERS. THE
DEVELOPERS HAVE TO PAY FOR IT,
AND IT'S PAST, UM ONTO CONSUMERS
. AND SO TO HIGHLIGHT HOW
EXTREME THE IMPLEMENTING VM T
CAN BE. AND THIS IS THIS IS NOT
EVEN, UM, IN A IN A IN A RURAL
AREA THAT PROPOSED GMT
MITIGATION FREE RANGE FROM
50,000 TO 2 MILLION PER NEW HOME
FOR A RECENT HOUSING PROJECT OUT
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY. UM IT FACED
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION AND
ULTIMATELY WAS NOT APPROVED. BUT
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF IMPLEMENTING
THIS. THIS POLICY ON A ON A
BROAD SCALE. UM CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT ONLY A
SUPPLY ISSUE, IT'S AN AFFORDABLE
ABILITY ISSUE AND THE MEDIAN
HOME PRICES IN THE STATE
CONTINUED TO SOAR AND MANY
FAMILIES ARE FORCED TO BUY OR
RENT IN THE SUBURBS OR RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE TO FIND
HOUSING THAT FITS THEIR BUDGET.
THE VM T MITIGATION HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON RURAL
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS HOME TO
OVER 50% OF THE STATE'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND IT
AND IN RURAL CALIFORNIA, MANY
RESIDENTS HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
COMMUTE LONG DISTANCES DUE TO
THE LACK. OR UNRIPE RELIABILITY
OF PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. AND
FRANKLY, THIS ISN'T THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. BUT
FRANKLY, UM, THE WAY WE HAVE SET
UP OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS,
IS THAT THE REGIONAL AND SO THEY
DON'T THEY DON'T STRETCH INTO
THE OTHER REGION LIKE THIS SELF.
THE BAY AREA REGION DOESN'T
REALLY GO. SOUTH OF GILROY,
WHICH LEAVES OUT ALL OF MONTEREY
COUNTY AND SAN BENITO COUNTY.
AND IT DOESN'T GO OVER TO MERCED
COUNTY, WHICH IS WHERE LOS MANOS
IS LOCATED. AND WHERE YOU SEE,
INCREDIBLE. UM UM, THAT CREDIBLE
AND AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
DRIVING OVER PACHECO PASS IN
ORDER TO GET INTO THE BAY AREA.
SO, UM SO I MEAN, I COULD GO ON
AND ON ON ON THE KIND OF WHITE
NOT KIND OF, BUT ABSOLUTELY HOW
THIS HAS AN IMPACT IN OUR IN IN
RURAL AREAS AND THE DISCONNECT
BETWEEN TRYING TO SET TRYING TO
WORK ON 22 GOALS AT THE SAME
TIME THAT HAVE ABSOLUTE IMPACT
ON ON EACH OTHER. UM QUITE
FRANKLY, A COLLEAGUE AND I WERE
THINKING OF DOING A BILL THAT
WOULD RESTRICT JOB IS INVESTING
IN ANY OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE BUILDING THEIR HOUSING, AND
THEY ONLY INVEST IN BMT IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. BUT UM, WE DECIDED
NOT TO TAKE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT, UM,
WHICH WOULD BE FABULOUSLY
UNPOPULAR, BUT IT IT'S A
REFLECTION OF HOW WE SET UP
THESE GOALS. AND THEN WE DON'T
LOOK AT WHETHER WE'RE MAKING IT
EASY TO ACTUALLY MEET THOSE
GOALS. SO SB 7068 AS AMENDED,
WILL REQUIRE CARB TO WORK WITH
THE KEY PARTNERS, INCLUDING THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH,
UM DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS AND KEY
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS THAT
CONDUCT A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY.
OF HOW THE EMPTY HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN ANY POSITIVE OR
NET NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES. AS A
RESULT, I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT
OPR KIND OF LEFT THE DOOR OPEN
BY SAYING WELL, LOCALLY, YOU CAN
TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND YOU IF YOU
CAN COME UP WITH SOME MITIGATION
MEASURES. UM YOU CAN UTILIZE
THOSE. THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS
YOU'RE TALKING TO COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE VERY LITTLE RESOURCES.
UM. MENDOTA FIREBALL. THEY'RE
ALL LOOKING TO MAINTAIN THEIR
BASIC MUNICIPAL SERVICES AND.
MANY OF THEM DON'T EVEN HAVE IT.
ENGINEERS TO, UM TO ENSURE WATER
QUALITY ISSUES THEY HAVE TO HIRE
. THEY HAVE TO CONTRACT SO TO
SET UP UP, UM, ESCAPE HATCH THAT
IS SUBJECT TO LITIGATION, AND
THAT THAT IS UNREALISTIC AND
DOESN'T WORK DOESN'T MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THAT THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT DOING A STUDY MAY MAKE
SENSE. UM WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND,
UM, WHAT OTHER METHODOLOGY WOULD
WORK WITH VM T. WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE SITUATION A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY. DO I SUPPORT THE
EFFORT THAT BMT IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING
THAT IS IN YOUR REPORT. I
BELIEVE IN THE PROBLEM IS ITS
APPLICATION. AND SO THE QUESTION
BECOMES. DO WE SET UP EXEMPTIONS
OR DO WE LOOK AT A DIFFERENT WAY
OF TRYING TO MEET OUR VM T GOALS
BY REQUIRING TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES? TO WORK ACROSS, UH,
LINES OR BY SAYING WE'RE GOING
TO PUT RESOURCES INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES, AND AS YOU KNOW,
THE AIR QUALITY IS AMONG THE
WORST IN IN, UM IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, FRESNO IS RATED NUMBER
NINTH, IS THE NINTH WORST CITY
IN THE COUNTRY FOR AIR QUALITY.
IT'S A BIG DEAL. PEOPLE WANT IT
SOLVED, BUT BUT WE'RE STRUGGLING
WITH ALSO TRYING TO BUILD
HOUSING. AND SO, UM, THE
RECOMMENDATION. I THINK THERE'S
SOME SOME SOME MORE. UM THINGS
WERE GOING TO WANT TO STUDY IN
THIS AND IF THEY IF THE STUDY
CHANGES, I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COME BACK. BUT ONE OF THE PIECES
OF AH, THE LIST. IT'S HERE IN
THE REPORT IS A GOOD START, BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO TO
UNDERSTAND THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN VM T O. AND IF I COULD
ON E. THAT SHOULD BE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT ONLY TALKING ABOUT
ELECTRIFICATION STATE HAS MADE A
COMMITMENT TO HYDROGEN VEHICLES
REFLECTED IN THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A PRODUCERS OF HYDROGEN
VEHICLES. UM THAT, UM THEY HAVE
A ROBUST PRESENCE IN THE STATE.
SO I THINK THAT SHOULD SAY ZERO
EMISSION, BUT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN VM T AND HOUSING
PRIORITIES THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED BY LAW. WHETHER
WORDS HOW DOES THIS WORK
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT, UM,
GENERATE THE HOUSING THAT WE
NEED, BUT ALSO, UM, PRIORITIZES
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
BECAUSE I ABSOLUTELY AGREE.
WE'VE GOT IT PRIORITIZE THAT,
BUT BUT, UM THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION IS THAT MOST PEOPLE IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA DON'T LIVE
WITHIN 10 MILES OF WHERE THEY
WORK. THEY JUST DON'T AND, UM
ONE SIZE DOESN'T. ALWAYS WORK
FOR EVERYBODY, SO I'LL LEAVE IT
AT THAT. HANDSOME IT. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS. I
KNOW THAT THE CBI A IS, UM MAYBE
AN OPPOSITION AND, UM, I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AS
WELL. SURE UM, BEFORE WE MOVE ON
, JUST, UM JUST TO CLARIFY ONE
OF YOUR COMMENTS THAT I KNOW
THAT DURING THE CONTAINMENT
CONSTRAINTS, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, AS
OPPOSED TO HERE IN EQ, SO THE
ANALYSIS IS BASED ON THE BILL
AND PRINT CORRECT. YES AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT MAY GO BACK TO
HOUSING. UM SO WE'LL MAKE SURE
TO RULE THE WHOLE THING, RIGHT?
OKAY WELL, LET'S UM GIVE ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO MAKE COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. COME ON UP. GREAT
THANK YOU, SENATOR STEVE CRUZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
SENATOR CAVALLERO MENTIONED OUR
POSITION WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
WORKING WITH HERE FOR. I THINK
ABOUT THREE YEARS ARE OVER THREE
DIFFERENT CYCLES TO TRY TO
REASSESS THE M T. UM YOU KNOW
THE IS IT WORKING OR IF IT IS
WORKING AS INTENDED, WE NEED TO
REEVALUATE THE UNDERLYING POLICY
BECAUSE CLEARLY AS AS MENTIONED
IT HAS HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON
HOUSING VM T THE MITIGATION FEES
THEIR LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE
ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE EMPTY
GUIDELINES. WE AGREE WITH YOU
ENTIRELY ON THE ORIGIN LIKE
WHERE IT STARTED WITH SP 743
THEY DISCUSSION WE WERE HAVING
THE TIME AS HEAD OF THE
STREAMLINE INFILL. IT SORT OF
WORKED INTO NOW. THIS TOOL
THAT'S MAKING HOUSING AND MUCH
OF THE HOUSING THAT'S BUILT. WE
DO A LOT OF INFO HOUSING.
THERE'S HOUSING OUTSIDE OF THAT
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE. YOU
MENTIONED SAN DIEGO EXAMPLE OF 2
MILLION. I THINK IN YOUR OWN
DISTRICT, THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
45,000 IN FRESNO. SO UM, YOU
KNOW, CLEARLY FOR US. I MEAN,
YOU'VE HEARD THE PHRASE LIKE
DRIVE UNTIL YOU CAN AFFORD. I
MEAN, THAT'S WHERE MOST PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA ARE IN THAT
POSITION. THEY DON'T WANT TO
HAVE TO DRIVE. BUT THAT'S WHERE
HOMES ARE MORE AFFORDABLE, SO WE
WANT TO SPEND IT. TIME WITH HER
AND YOUR STAFF. UM AND THEN IF
IT'S HOUSING TO TRY TO WORK ON
IT AND SEE. IS THERE A WAY TO IS
THE STUDY THE RIGHT WAY TO COME
UP WITH THE INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED TO REASSESS, BUT CLEARLY
WANT TO BE PARTNERS IN THAT
CONVERSATION, SO THANK YOU.
EXCUSE ME. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
MARK WALSH. TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. THE RIVERSIDE
COMMISSION IS IN FAVOR AND
CONCEPT OF THE LANGUAGES. WE
READ IT, AND WE DO ENCOURAGE
MOVEMENT OF THE BILL TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, TYLER MANZI ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES,
CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MR CRUZ. LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS,
MEMORIES FOR HIM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO RAISE OBJECTIONS OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? ALL
RIGHT, AND NOW WE'RE NO LONGER
GOING TO THE PHONE LINES. SO
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK. BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS, THOUGHTS
FROM THE MEMBERS. YEAH, ANYONE?
YEAH. OKAY. SO MOVED BY. SENATOR
TATO APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
COMMENTS, SENATOR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS DIFFICULT, IMPORTANT ISSUE,
AND OF COURSE, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. THERE'S NO ONE SIZE DOES
NOT FIT ALL AND VERY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE. I
KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET OUT HERE. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS, SO
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR TO
WANT THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR CHAIR,
AND I APPRECIATE, UM APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK. I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE RIVERSIDE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. THEY
HADN'T ONE OF THE REAL QUICK
EXAMPLES AS THEY HAD A TRAFFIC
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS TO HIGHWAY
THAT THEY NEEDED TO BUILD, AND
THEY COULDN'T DO IT BECAUSE IT
WOULD INCREASE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. IN OTHER WORDS,
RIVERSIDE IS HOUSING A LOT OF
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE IN THE ALLEY
AREA, AND, UM, AND TO NOT MAKE A
TRAFFIC SAFETY IMPROVEMENT
BECAUSE IT INCREASES THE
POTENTIAL FOR PEOPLE THAN LIVING
OUT THERE. TO UM SAFELY USE THE
HIGHWAY DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME. SO UM, I THINK
THERE'S SOME FIXES. IT'S THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SOME OF
THIS STUFF, BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE AND LISTENING AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT. LET'S CALL HER ON. RIGHT?
SB 768 DO PASS TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. ALLEN AND I, DOLLY!
GONZALES IS I ORTEZ HØI MENJIVAR
MENJIVAR I WHEN I KNOW SKINNER.
OKAY WELL, HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
CENTER SKINNER. SHE'S ABLE TO
MAKE IT BACK. THANK YOU. WE'LL
MAKE SURE OKAY. THANK YOU,
DOLLY. AYE. FINE BOOK. ALRIGHT
FANTASTIC. AH! THANK YOU,
SENATORS. ALRIGHT NOW, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S GO NEXT TO OUR
COLLEAGUE, SENATOR WEINER, WHO'S
HERE TO PRESENT HIS BILL. ITEM
NUMBER ONE IN YOUR AGENDAS. SP
312 GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR I WANNA APPRECIATE YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW YOU AND I HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT
THIS EXTENSIVELY THAT THIS BILL
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS WITH THE GOAL OF MAKING
SURE THAT SENATE BILL 886 IS
FULLY IMPLEMENTED BY UC CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COLLEAGUES
YOU'LL RECALL BECAUSE YOU HEARD
THIS COMMITTEE THAT THIS BILL
FOR THOSE WHO WERE ON THE
COMMITTEE IN 2021 SENATE, BILL
886 WAS A NOW A LAW THAT I
AUTHORED IN THIS COMMITTEE
PASSED TO CREATE A SECRET
EXEMPTION WHEN YOU SEE CSU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE BUILDING
ON CAMPUS STUDENT HOUSING, WE
KNOW WE HAVE A MASSIVE SHORTAGE
OF STUDENT HOUSING AT ARE
PARTICULARLY AT OUR PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. AN
OUTRAGEOUS RATE OF HOMELESSNESS
AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS, STUDENTS
WHO ARE LIVING IN THEIR CARS WHO
ARE HOT HOPPING AROUND AT MOTELS
OR COUCH SURFING AND JUST AS
EXTREMELY HARMFUL, IT TAKES AWAY
FROM THEIR EDUCATION. AND WE
NEED TO CHANGE IT. WE KNOW THAT
OUR COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES WANT
TO BUILD ON CAMPUS STUDENT
HOUSING. WE EVEN HAVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, WHICH HAVE NOT DONE SO
IN THE PAST, WHO ARE THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND EVEN MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION? WE ALSO KNOW
THAT UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN NIMBYISM GETS IN THE
WAY WE'VE SEEN THIS A MOST
EXTENSIVELY AT UC BERKELEY,
WHERE WE HAVE HAD TO INTERVENE
AS A LEGISLATOR MULTIPLE TIMES
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU C BERKELEY
CAN BUILD A STUDENT HOUSING.
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU WHEN WE
WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED SB 86. I
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
INTENSELY CONTROVERSIAL AND I
WAS PREPARED TO DEAL WITH EVERY
MICRO LOCAL COMMUNITY ISSUE AT
EVERY CAMPUS IN THE ENTIRE STATE
, AND WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
MINOR OPPOSITION. RELATING TO A
COUPLE OF UC CAMPUSES. THERE WAS
REALLY THE MINIMUS OPPOSITIONS
OF THE BILL, BECAUSE I THINK
PEOPLE REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF EMPOWERING OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
QUICKLY APPROVE AND BUILD NEW
STUDENT HOUSING, SO THAT LAW IS
IN EFFECT. WE HAVE SINCE
REALIZED THAT WE NEED TO DO SOME
CLEANUP TO IT TO MAKE IT FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. BLE THE BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY ADDRESSES ONE ISSUE
UNDER AMENDMENT PUT IN BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN 2021. THE PROJECTS
HAVE TO BE LEED PLATINUM AND
HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED AS SUCH
BEFORE THEY CAN INVOKE THE
EXEMPTION THAT DOESN'T WORK IN
THE REAL WORLD BECAUSE OF HOW
CERTIFICATION OF LEED STANDARDS
WORKS, SO THE BILL WILL SWITCH
THAT TO REQUIRE CERTAIN THAT HAS
TO HAVE TO SHOW THAT YOU WOULD
EFFECTIVELY BE ELIGIBLE. FOR
THAT LEAD STATUS, BUT YOU DON'T
GET THE CERTIFICATION. YOU DON'T
NEED IT UNTIL THE CERTIFICATE OF
OCCUPANCY. YOU'RE ON THE PATH
TOWARD IT. BUT YOU'RE ON THE
PATH TOWARDS YOU CAN SHOW THAT
YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET
THERE, BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE A FORMALLY APPROVED AND
CERTIFIED UNTIL CERTIFICATE OF
OCCUPANCY. AND IF ANY OF THE
COLLEGES OR UNIVERSITIES PLAY
GAMES, THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR DOING THAT. I'M
SURE THEY WILL NOT PLAY GAMES.
AND SO JUST TO BE CLEAR WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. YOU KNOW, WE'RE
WORKING WITH AH, THE U. C AND IN
PARTICULAR TO GET MORE FEEDBACK
FROM THEM ABOUT MAKING SURE IT'S
FULLY IMPLEMENTED BLE AND SO
WE'LL CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
, WHICH WITH ME TODAY IS
JORDAN'S PENINA CORBA HALL FROM
CALIFORNIA. UM B AND, AS YOU
KNOW, IN, UH OH, YEAH. CROW FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. GREAT
WHAT'S YOUR FOR ME? THANK YOU,
SENATOR. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME WAS JORDAN. BANANA
CARVAJAL, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR COLOR FOR A, UM, BE HERE TO
SPEAK AS AS PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
SB 312. THE HOUSING CRISIS OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IMMINENT THREAT TO
THE SUCCESS OF THE NEXT
GENERATION. IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER THE COST OF HOUSING
MIXED COLLEGE EDUCATION
INFEASIBLE FOR MANY STUDENTS, IT
MAKES IT HARDER FOR COLLEGE
FACULTY AND STATUS SUPPORT A
WORLD RENOWNED PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM. AS A SENATOR MENTIONED
IN 2022, THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB 886,
WHICH RIGHTED EXEMPTION FROM
SEQUA. FOR STUDENTS AND FACULTY
HOUSING PROJECTS AT UCC SUS IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HOWEVER ONE
OF THE QUALIFICATION FOR THESE
PROJECTS REQUIRE ALL BUILDINGS
TO MEET LEED PLATINUM
CERTIFICATION, WHICH INCLUDES
INCLUDE NUMEROUS PROVISIONS TO
DETERMINE IF A BUILDING CAUSE I
FOR CERTIFICATION. SOME OF THESE
DETERMINES, HOWEVER, CANNOT BE
MADE UNTIL BUILDINGS OCCUPIED.
AS WE 312 IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE TIMING
ISSUE BY REQUIRING THESE
BUILDINGS TO QUALIFY. FOR LEAD
PLATINUM CERTIFICATION RIGHT TO
RECEIVE THIS CERTIFICATION.
WHICH CAN BE ACHIEVED BEFORE
OCCUPANCY. AND IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SP 312. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS BEN AND ELLIOT KROO. I'M
A THIRD YEAR AT UC SANTA CRUZ
APPOINTED OFFICER ON STUDENT
HOUSING WITH èC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND CO CHAIR OF THE
STUDENT HOMES COALITION, WHICH
IS A COLLECTIVE OF HIGHER ED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE WORKING
TO SOLVE THE STUDENT HOUSING
CRISIS. AND I KIND OF WANT TO
TAKE SOME TIME TODAY TO JUST
TALK ABOUT THE STUDENT LOAN
CRISIS AND HOW INSANE IT IS. WE
KNOW THAT IT'S GETTING WORSE,
ROUGHLY 20% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
10% OF CSU AND 5% OF U. C.
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS, UM AND ACCORDING
TO RECENT DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION, OVER HALF OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE HOUSING INSECURE,
AND THAT'S UP FROM 36% JUST FOUR
YEARS AGO, AND SO RECOGNIZING
THE CRISIS, THE STATE HAS
INVESTED $2.2 BILLION OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS AND STUDENT
HOUSING, WHICH IS FANTASTIC
WELCOME INVESTMENT AND IN
ADDITION TO THE 35 PROJECTS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN GIVEN FUNDING OVER
70 COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
CURRENTLY STUDYING BUILDING
STUDENT HOUSING ON THEIR SITES.
SO WE KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF STUDENT HOUSING IS GOING
TO BE COMING. IT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY BENEFICIAL FOR FOLKS IN
THE PIPELINE. BUT POINT THING IS
THAT GLARING ISSUES STILL REMAIN
. NAMELY THE DUKE COULD HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT AND
LAWSUITS THAT HAVE HELD UP
PROJECT AT UC BERKELEY. UC L A.
U C. SAN DIEGO AND U. C DAVIS
AND U C. SANTA CRUZ. AND WHICH
IS WHAT S B 3 12-1. ATTENDING TO
FIX AND TO GIVE SOME PERSPECTIVE
ON WHAT THIS REAL WORLD IMPACT
LOOKS LIKE. I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE AT UC SANTA
CRUZ. UM THERE'S A PROJECT
CALLED STUDENT HOUSING WEST AT
UC SANTA CRUZ. IT'S PROJECTED TO
ADD ABOUT 3000 BEDS, WHICH IS
OVER 25% INCREASE OVER EXISTING
HOUSING CAPACITY, WHICH IS MUCH
NEEDED AT THE U. C. WHERE 90% OF
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND ITS PROJECT
THAT'S REPLACING AN ALREADY
EXISTING FAMILY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND BUILDING
DEVELOPMENT IN AN AREA THAT'S
LOCATED ON BY ROADS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ON ALL SIDES AND
THAT PROJECT WAS APPROVED IN
2019 WHEN I WAS IN 10TH GRADE.
UM HOWEVER, THAT PROJECT HAS
FACED TWO SEPARATE LAWSUITS FROM
NEARBY NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH HAS
STALLED THE PROJECT FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS. AND IN THOSE FIVE
YEARS, CONSTRUCTION COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE RISEN ON AVERAGE
BY 44.8% ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION COST
INDEX. AND SO YOU, CSC FINALLY
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO BREAK GROUND IN
STRING. BUT TO GIVE SOME
PERSPECTIVE, I WILL HAVE
COMPLETED 10TH GRADE 11TH GRADE
12TH GRADE. MY FIRST YEAR OF
COLLEGE, MY SECOND YEAR OF
COLLEGE AND MOST OF MY THIRD
YEAR OF COLLEGE BETWEEN THE TIME
THIS PROJECT WAS APPROVED BY THE
TIME THE PROJECT BROKE GROUND,
THAT'S ABSURD. I'M GOING TO
ACTUALLY BE GRADUATED BY THE END
OF THIS QUARTER, SO I WILL HAVE
NOT BETWEEN THE PRIME. THE
PROJECT WAS APPROVED AND BEHIND
THE PROJECT GOES FORWARD. I WILL
HAVE BEEN GONE AND THAT THING IS
A REALLY WEIRD WORLD IMPACT ON
PEOPLE. I WAS LOOKING FOR
HOUSING IN ONE OF MY CLASSES
BECAUSE I WAS ON THE HOUSING
SEARCH AND THAT THE STUDENT
BEHIND ME JUST AS TRAINING. I
WAS LIKE, OH, YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
HOUSING. OH MY GOD. IT'S A
NIGHTMARE. AND HE WAS TALKING TO
ME AND HE WAS LIKE, YEAH, YOU
KNOW, I ACTUALLY COULDN'T FIND
HOUSING IN SANTA CRUZ BECAUSE IT
WAS TOO EXPENSIVE. SO I COMMUTED
FROM MY PARENTS' HOUSE IN
REDWOOD CITY EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
GET TO CLASS IS 100 MILES EVERY
SINGLE DAY THIS STUDENT WAS
DRIVING BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE IN SANTA CRUZ,
AND THEY DID THAT FOR TWO
QUARTERS. THAT IS INSANE, ABSURD
AND TALK ABOUT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
STUDENTS CAN LIVE WHERE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO SCHOOL, LET
ALONE THE SOCIETAL COSTS OF
STUDENTS NOT BEING ABLE TO
ACTUALLY ATTEND THE UNIVERSITIES
THAT THEY ARE BEING EDUCATED AT.
AND SO I JUST REALLY THINK THAT
WE SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWING A LOT
OF NIMBY HOMEOWNERS DE FACTO
VETO AUTHORITY OVER THE ABILITY
FOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS OUR
PUBLIC COLLEGE SYSTEMS, WHICH IS
THE GREATEST PUBLIC INSTITUTION
OF UPWARD MOBILITY WE HAVE IN
THIS STATE. LAST YEAR. ONLY 65
UP SO YEAH. LAST YEAR, ONLY 65%
OF FRESHMAN APPLICANTS WERE
ADMITTED TO A èC COMPARED TO
84% IN 1990. WE CAN SEE THAT THE
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS AT UC IS DECLINING
DIRECTLY AS A RESULT OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE LACK OF
EXPANSION THERE AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO SOLVE THIS CLIMATE
CRISIS BY INVESTING IN PEOPLE.
AND THAT STARTS WITH ENSURING
CALIFORNIANS CAN ATTEND OUR
WORLD CLASS EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GREAT UM, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTARY. LET'S HEAR NEXT
FROM ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
WAIT AND SUPPORTED THE BILL. ANY
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. ANYONE HERE WANTS TO RAISE
OKAY, WE'LL GO TO THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. I'M AN ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. YOU KNOW,
QUITE FRANKLY, UM WE'RE ALL A
LITTLE, UM FRUSTRATED THAT THIS
ISSUE OF PLATINUM VERSUS GOLD
WASN'T FLAGGED EARLIER. IT WAS
CERTAINLY NEVER THE INTENT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO JAM UP THESE
KINDS OF PROJECTS, AND I'M
REALLY GLAD YOU'RE WORKING HARD
TO REMEDY THIS ISSUE. I THINK
IT'S MY STRONG FEELING THAT YOU
KNOW. PROJECT MEETS SUCH A HIGH
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARD. IT
REALLY DOES MERIT A AN EXEMPTION
. THE THERE'S THE SORTS OF
SCENARIOS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE STUDENTS ARE, YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO. WE NEED TO. UM WHEN YOU
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A MAJOR
CHALLENGE WITH REGARDS TO
HOUSING ON OUR CAMPUSES, AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED, AND WHEN YOU GET
THIS HOUSING ONLINE, SO I'M I'M
BIG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I'M CO
AUTHORING IT AND, UM CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO SEE YOU GETTING THIS
ISSUE REMEDIED. SENATOR DOLLY
WOULD LIKE TO JUST ALL MOVE THE
BILL. I WANT TO GET IT MOVING. I
WANTED TO SAY TO THE WITNESS WE
TRY TO BUILD A RESERVOIR FOR 50
YEARS. AND FINALLY, LAST YEAR WE
GOT IT MOVING. SO I'M HOPING
YOU'LL STAY ENGAGED IN THE
PROCESS BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS WHY IT COSTS SO MUCH IN
CALIFORNIA, AND A LOT OF THOSE
DECISIONS WILL AFFECT ALL THOSE
DECISIONS ARE MADE RIGHT HERE IN
THIS CAPITAL, SO WELCOME TO THE
PROCESS. LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING
HOUSING, SO MY GRANDKIDS WILL BE
IN IT. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT SO THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS? QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AGAIN, SENATOR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND THANKS FOR
THE WITNESSES ARE COMING INTO TO
SPEAK. GOOD OPPORTUNITY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. I WANT TO
THANK OUR WITNESS FOR COMING UP
FROM SANTA CRUZ TAKING THE
TRAIN. GO SLUGS. OH, GOOD. THERE
YOU GO. YEAH GREAT WILL BE A
FASTER TRAIN ONE DAY, BUT AH, UM
, MR SHAW. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS BILL. AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S CALL
THE ROLL. SP 312 DO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALAN
ALAN, I DALI DALI. I GONZALES
GONZALES. I FOLLOW BUT I MANAGED
OVER. I KNOW WHEN I SCANNER I
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL, OKAY,
REALLY TELL US. SHE WAS HERE.
SHE JUST WENT TO CLOSE OUT THE
VOTES IN JAIL GOVERNMENT 500.
YEAH. LET'S UH LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE FOR THE, UM FOR THE TWO
BILLS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
AGENDA. SB 312 DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAIR
VOTING? I'VE I SHARE VOTING I
SKINNER THIS IS 312 WIENER,
OKAY? SKINNER I THAT VOTE IS
OUT. A BILL IS OUT. SB 768. DO
PASS THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
CHAIR. VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING EYES. SKINNER I FIND THE
ONE BUILDS UP GREAT. THANK YOU.
SORRY. SORRY 6 TO 1 VIABLE FOR
IT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY APPRECIATE IT. AND
THANK YOU, SENATOR. LET'S RETURN
THE HEARING.